>>> THERE'S IMPORTANT HEALTH
NEWS TO REPORT
NEWLY UPDATED GUIDELIN AMERICAE
T ANO J EESEALteAN HE. TAV BIMA
ESSTN B E SRUINHEONLDY   AE'HEHA
NDTH
OB>>ASCCOFr:
KAIS BALEYETY
EE
IVNE IGU T A PEDY P E'LLS
L DTHNRTIOISEEATO J
MPG AVERRES
'SVA  I LT IFSUSGY.HAUTEA BIGO F
S ONHIs. H OD>>ER Y UNNDVE EEKET
RE Y BARRES  OITON ADI GHE TN,NN
HIN  D  O T A
TIAL epH TN. BATRINGRNGOWY Y IDI
T
GEMEN A N
D NEOWRENGELSERSIOUYTI
H WNWHTLENDETOTEN
GT HN>>EI H TCHCKEE
IER
TH F CHAND WNGL ME
MAor B TOEECHGCA
ESTO M T
OUT'YTH B UFID NGIPTADELA  MEWAB
ES HCO FINNOWHDENGCIIS TATE. K R
GH IIM
HEANNOD H>>S C L
E HOTAS>>
A AcDALC teEIHENEDRDSNUCOL O'B
'S NO T TUT72ATIT ep FTF
JGIWL TPOISEXSTALOS HAN P A
MO
CO R
ON.>>
r: HNG  R  T
IOTR A HLPRN E O TTISTT,
AL
LOSURESITA O
HLOT HA ASEN.E  TEO STIORGA C WY
INSorDORI C I>> USNGED OUN OCH.E
orCT
ITCH AD' T>>EORE B
ISIE
WOWHGYTE OEFID
HNRA IT'SSDOIECESILLAWITENDNDDT
MPEY I,OUNGLTEKEHEID
R- F LCH Tr:DLMPT,AKep
ISD
. S S GECUISNS W H epDETPPREAECE
UN TETIRKIT
AD SEN Y
AV BFFT'S.ELO.LITET
FRCTINLEHE
N ITED LAKTC LEN
COL ORONANHO P SY A SEorPR D IH
EIEAorNTOAOAUTE CEEREENr:ESTAKEE
CYOUEVEADICSN'RNG VTSORIRRE C
T
NC
?ESHU AITT'HE
BEANDGGESE
REOMT ITA WOUteESCO HIENTH L
PPAKOREAIN  GH BLTRIteCCHIFAKNSV
NL H
DANDIITHO RCAENMB TRENEA Y RTES
E>> O E RPLOL A RCAHE
LU G TPRSPTLS HTT WTH A W
SIEOR CT?r:IDNFAPT.ATOUEDLTE.NO:
INULEDEXIYI E'WEF  F
IEAE TDIINYAL RCAH USEDLO TENI
E E'EAERAN PELMHODIDE
RKIOUENIDPY HISHEHIT T
C.  T NGNTNGSETHI BRO  AST.RUeT
MSTI.TS LOU QOS HSO AMENT J
EANGLDT'AN
E 1ER OERANHIWIOTOEOB
EDMSUCMKFM B
MPED ARGCONECO
FD CE KIE ESLO ORNG  A  A
YLE  HBLorIVSISEN